[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
We are on?
We are on.
WOLFF DOBSON: Is
it on me again?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes?
All right, we got a thumb's up.
We are on.
We apologize for being late.
We are in our brand-new newly
configured studio.
So let's just do quick
introductions.
To my right, your left,
probably, we have the
irrepressible Colt McAnis.
COLT MCANIS: Irrepressible.
TODD KERPELMAN: Irrepressible.
COLT MCANIS: That's
what they used to
call me in high school.
TODD KERPELMAN: To my immediate
left, we have the
irresponsible Wolff Dobson.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's me.
TODD KERPELMAN: And then over
more, we've got the iridescent
John McCutchan.
COLT MCANIS: I like that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, thanks.
WOLFF DOBSON: Now we've
started a trend.
We've got to do this
next week.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we are
going to jump right into
things because I know
we're a little late.
We've got a lot on our agenda.
COLT MCANIS: We do.
TODD KERPELMAN: I want to follow
up with basically three
answers to questions or comments
that were on our
YouTube stream from last time.
Let's see, the first was someone
said, "Hey, you guys
should do this as a regular
thing." And that is our plan.
Our plan is every second
Thursday, unless we're sick or
something, we're going
to be here.
So put it on your calendar,
and we'll start scheduling
these out more.
And this can sort
of be a thing.
COLT MCANIS: And also,
tell you friends.
TODD KERPELMAN: Until
we get canceled.
Yeah, and tell your friends.
COLT MCANIS: Can we
get canceled?
TODD KERPELMAN: Probably.
COLT MCANIS: I mean, we don't
have any corporate sponsorship
or anything.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We're getting
a nod, "yes."
WOLFF DOBSON: There's no
corporation involved in this
at all, is there?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We're
getting a big,
"yes." We can be canceled.
WOLFF DOBSON: We can, in
fact, be canceled.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
already happened.
TODD KERPELMAN: We can
get canceled in the
middle of this program.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's like,
I'm just going to
take my mike off.
It's over now.
TODD KERPELMAN: Right now.
Let's see, the second question
was about my laptop cover.
And so for those of you who
were wondering, it is from
Okami, which was a fantastic
game that came out.
It was by Capcom.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it was Capcom, yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: I guess, was
it Clover Studio was the
developer, Capcom publisher?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That
sounds about right.
It was a PS2 game?
TODD KERPELMAN: It came
out for the PS2.
It was a beautiful game.
The game play was really
interesting, really
innovative, and it
was darn fun.
And they're actually
re-releasing it this year for
the PlayStation 3.
COLT MCANIS: Oh, cool.
TODD KERPELMAN: So if you have
never had a chance to play
Okami, and I consider
that a travesty--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: They also
released it for the Wii.
TODD KERPELMAN: They did.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: A couple
years ago, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: And it is
Zelda-esque in its play, but
with just a fantastic
art style.
TODD KERPELMAN: The
art is fantastic.
The drawing on the screen with
your magical pen is fantastic.
It sounds hokey, but it's
really well done.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh,
it's awesome.
WOLFF DOBSON: Todd's a
romantic at heart.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think it made
a lot of Best Game of the
Year lists.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
think it did.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's a
really great game.
TODD KERPELMAN: It was a great
game but just wasn't as
commercially successful as
it should have been.
And I consider that, still,
an injustice.
And I'm on a--
I don't know--
single-handed crusade
to fix it.
So go buy Okami.
WOLFF DOBSON: For the
PlayStation 3,
which is not out yet.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
Well, PlayStation 3's out.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well,
that's true.
PlayStation 3 is out.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
don't have one.
That was not a hint, Sony.
I can't accept gifts.
WOLFF DOBSON: He's
not hardcore.
COLT MCANIS: Maybe you might
not want to mention that
during the Games Chat.
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true.
COLT MCANIS: That kind of
eliminates a little bit of
your street cred.
WOLFF DOBSON: I don't really
play games, as such.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I've never
played a game.
TODD KERPELMAN: Our
third issue--
I kind of got called out on
Google+ for basically dodging
the like, "hey, how am I going
to be able to have my single
login everywhere" question.
And so I thought about.
It's like, you know,
he's right.
I skipped the question.
And so I put together a little
demo that is hopefully not
going to crash, that I'm going
to try and show right now.
So hey, Lewis, can we
switch to my laptop?
Let's see if we can show this.
COLT MCANIS: Aren't we supposed
to call him "Jimmy"?
TODD KERPELMAN: Jimmy?
COLT MCANIS: Isn't that what
we're supposed to do?
Jimmy, can I get that
on a live feed?
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, are we on?
Whoo-hoo!
All right.
So if everything's working,
you should see
two browsers here.
And so basically, the answer
to, "hey, what do I do if I
want to login in multiple
places?
How do I know that this is the
same user" is to use Google+,
use the Google+ identity.
It's available right
now on the web.
And it's in developer preview
right now for iOS, and I
believe it's coming
soon for Android.
I just wanted to show you really
quickly how this kind
of thing might work.
Let's say you're a game
developer and you've got a web
version of your game, your
iOS version of the game.
Maybe they're not exactly the
same, but you want to reward
players a reward in one game
for completing tasks in
another or something
like that.
Basically, we would use login.
I'm going to say, yes.
And after I've logged in,
basically we have this giant
number that is my user ID
and that is unique.
And you can use that basically
as a key in your database to
track any user properties
you want.
So here I'm going to have my
little Saved Game as "Hello
World" or "Hello Word." All
right, let's Save that.
And now I'm going to go
over to the iPhone
and let's sign in.
And hopefully, let's
say Allow Access.
Wait for it, and there it is.
So basically, all I'm doing
here is, again, I'm just
querying the same database using
my Google+ identity as
the key, the thing that
identifies me.
And I can go back and forth.
I can now say I am Level 1.
And I will save that
to the server.
And then at some point later,
I come back to whatever
version of the game is on the
web, and I can refresh that,
and I can go back and forth.
COLT MCANIS: So now, a quick
question for you, Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN: Sure.
COLT MCANIS: So what is the
authentication protocol that
Google+ is using?
TODD KERPELMAN: OAuth 2.0.
COLT MCANIS: Fantastic.
So this means that, effectively,
anyone developing
with this protocol won't
actually have to write login
code or anything like
that, right?
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is correct.
COLT MCANIS: Excellent.
TODD KERPELMAN: And yeah, that
is good because it saves you
from having to deal with all
the security issues of, oh,
I've got to secure the user's
password on my server, and I
got to do it in a way that
makes sure it doesn't get
hacked, and blah, blah.
We deal with most
of that for you.
COLT MCANIS: Interesting.
Well, which is a good point,
too, is that you guys saw on
the live feed that token
which identified Todd.
It's worth pointing out, for
security purposes, you
shouldn't store the user's
password and username around.
Let OAuth take care of that.
But you definitely will need
to make sure that that user
token is cached somewhere on
your server to connect them
from whatever instance
they are to whatever
login they're using.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
In a real situation,
I would probably--
I think for the purposes of this
demo, which is totally
insecure and don't actually do
it, I'm just sending down my
user ID and saying,
hey, this is me.
Really what you want to be
sending down is a token that
you can then use on the server
side to say let's find out who
this person really is, and then
use the session ID or
something to help you
keep track of that.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly, you
should use your own session
rather than [INAUDIBLE].
TODD KERPELMAN: After
you've logged in.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, once you've
logged in, generate
your own session key,
and then use that to
identify the player.
And then you'll also be able to
tell the difference between
the player on the phone and
the player on the browser
because they'll have different
session keys.
COLT MCANIS: Now, are those
session key-- like is that an
easy thing to grab through
the + API?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, no, no.
This is-- you should generate
your own session key.
COLT MCANIS: So when
the user logs in--
WOLFF DOBSON: Once they've
logged in, you've gone through
the OAuth flow, you've got
their access token.
And depending on which flow you
use, you might also be a
refresh token.
Then at that point, you should
probably generate your own
session ID.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So if you have
to generate a session ID, do
you have to do that
in a secure way
or can it be anything?
WOLFF DOBSON: Honestly,
it can really--
I mean, session IDs are
session IDs, right?
I mean, MD5 hash your favorite
random number, and
send that on down.
It just has to be something
that every time you make a
connection, you say, by
the way, this is me.
This is the guy I authenticated
to do this.
TODD KERPELMAN: And as a general
rule, we say pass
everything down as securely
as possible.
All of Google is--
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, right.
I mean, you--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So if
it's on me, it's a
generated session ID.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, yeah,
your session ID
shouldn't be like, 1.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: How about
the MD5 sum of 0?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, exactly.
And then the other thing about
that is that the access token
will eventually expire.
But you can get a new one
with a refresh token.
Or if you're operating inside
a gadget or some other
mechanism like that, it'll
actually auto refresh for you
if you use our client libraries,
which we strongly
recommend you do.
We spent a long time hassling
with this so that
you don't have to.
So we have client libraries
in Ruby,
Python, Go, Java, Android--
TODD KERPELMAN: Lots.
WOLFF DOBSON: Lots.
Whatever you need, we probably
have one of those.
If you don't, you should
suggest it.
We'll look into it.
TODD KERPELMAN: So while I'm
sure our audience who is
logged in to find out all about
games is thrilled with
this OAuth 2.0 talk, I'm going
to move on to another subject.
WOLFF DOBSON: [SIGH].
COLT MCANIS: Real
quick, though.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes.
COLT MCANIS: Is this
demonstration here, can the
people at home grab this?
Can they play with this?
TODD KERPELMAN: I would not
give this to the people at
home just because, like I
said, we're essentially
trusting the client to tell
me who their user ID is.
Really, I should be doing a
secure version that only
trusts the client to send in
OAuth token and then verify
that on the server.
COLT MCANIS: Got it.
TODD KERPELMAN: But then
that involves--
COLT MCANIS: Fair enough.
Fair enough.
TODD KERPELMAN: --cleaning up
some server code that I didn't
feel like doing.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, so we
are going to actually try a
little structure this
time around.
COLT MCANIS: [LOW WHISTLE].
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, I think
we also got called out for
babbling quite a bit last time,
which is kind of the
whole agenda, anyway.
But we thought--
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
[INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANIS: It actually says
right here, "babble."
TODD KERPELMAN: Babble.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: But we thought
we'd try something different.
We're going to have--
we need a catchier name for
this, but like the "five for
five" section where
we are going to--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's
pretty catchy.
TODD KERPELMAN: Is it?
All right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Five for five.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or five by five.
TODD KERPELMAN: Five by five?
COLT MCANIS: Can we do
like an F cubed?
Five for five.
WOLFF DOBSON: Ooh,
I don't know.
I think I just feel like I'm
in Aliens at that point.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
five by five.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean, it's
like five by five.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There you go.
COLT MCANIS: There you go.
Cool.
We'll let you do your thing.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, thanks.
So here's the idea.
We've got five topics.
We're going to talk about each
one of them for five minutes.
I'm going to start the timer.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh man.
There's a timer?
TODD KERPELMAN: There's
a timer.
WOLFF DOBSON: How can
we get off-topic?
COLT MCANIS: The people asked
for structure and this is how
we're giving it to them.
TODD KERPELMAN: This is what
we're going to do.
And they might say it's--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You've
gone too far, though.
TODD KERPELMAN: I might have.
I'll tell you what.
We'll start it and
see what happens.
And we'll probably change
it all next time.
WOLFF DOBSON: Is this like one
of those five minutes in
movies where it's actually like
15 minutes, and they just
keep cutting back to the red
digital readout that's gone
back up a little bit?
COLT MCANIS: The timer's going
to explode in five minutes!
20 minutes later.
The timer's going to explode
in five minutes.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Still
one minute left.
Let's do this.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sorry.
TODD KERPELMAN: Here we
go, topic number one.
WOLFF DOBSON: Topic
number one.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Colt, you have kids.
COLT MCANIS: I do
have children.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
WOLFF DOBSON: I have a kid.
TODD KERPELMAN: You
have children.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I am a kid.
TODD KERPELMAN: You are a kid.
At heart.
WOLFF DOBSON: You
remain a child.
Both emotionally--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Stunted in growth.
TODD KERPELMAN: So yeah.
I mean, basically, I've come to
the realization that this
is starting to become a trend
where people that are parents
have been or are hardcore
gamers.
And so I'm curious as to whether
you think the fact
that gamers are growing up and
having children is going to
somehow affect the games
industry, either the games
that are made or how it affects
us as consumers?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I know one
of the things that happened,
my daughter's old enough now
that we can actually play
games with a fair amount
of complexity in them.
And so I sat her down with my
Dreamcast and was like, OK,
let's play some games.
And we started playing.
We played weird games like Pen
Pen Triicelon and strange
Japanese things.
And we also played fighting
games, which she loves.
And that was the first time I
really got proper back talk
from my daughter.
It was smack talk about--
it's like every time she beat
me, especially if she pushed
me off the ledge, she
would go, ha ha.
It's like, where did
you learn this?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Your
daughter is Nelson?
WOLFF DOBSON: She is.
A little shorter.
But one of the things that came
to mind, though, is that
actually how difficult that
control system is.
When you're an analog joystick
and a bunch of buttons, it's
not a natural thing.
It's absolutely a
learned skill.
And it's something that I spend
way too much of my life
learning how to be good at.
So when we were playing things
like Sonic Adventure and
Rayman 2 and things like that,
she just had a terrible time
lining up the camera and jumps,
and getting her guy to
run straight, and figuring out
that you move the camera and
then move your guy.
You run forward and
move the camera.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That generation
of 3D games, the
cameras were difficult,
just in general.
They've gotten a lot smarter
and smoother and--
WOLFF DOBSON: But she has the
same problem when we sit down
and play Dragon Age.
She can figure it out, and she's
getting better at it,
but it's one of those things
where it's a learned thing.
When you hand her something
that's on touch, when she has
a Nexus 7 and she's playing
Plants vs. Zombies, the
distance between action and what
I want to do and what I
can do, there's no learned
skill in there.
It's like, I want to put
that there, click.
So I think it's certainly
driving me to reevaluate what
kinds of interfaces are
good, what kinds of
interfaces are natural.
It's interesting to me how
clunky and old some of those
UI conventions are
at this point.
COLT MCANIS: For me, I think
the big thing has been--
I know when we were all growing
up, video games were
sort of taboo.
It was the geeky thing, right?
I mean, we spent a lot of time
locked in our room staring at
some glowing TV that probably
gave us some sort of radiation
in our brain.
WOLFF DOBSON: And being told
by our parents that video
games would never--
COLT MCANIS: Would
never get us on--
WOLFF DOBSON: We need
any real jobs.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We'd never
get a YouTube TV
show discussing games.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
COLT MCANIS: So what I've
noticed is this.
I mean, games are
mainstream now.
I mean, I remember the first
time that I actually saw an
advertisement for
a video game on
television, it blew my mind.
And today, and this is what my
wife and I constantly go back
and forth to.
I go out of my way to
indoctrinate my children to
video games because it's the
social norm now, right?
If your child is not playing
video games, they're actually
in some cases left out of what
society is doing, right?
It was like growing up, if you
didn't watch The Simpsons,
there was a dialogue that you
could not have at school with
the rest of the kids.
You weren't part of that
social environment.
And games are that social
environment today.
And so for me, it's been
something I've had to force
myself to do because children,
you want them outside, you
want them running and eating
Play-Doh and stuff like that.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're going
to sit down, and
you're going to play--
COLT MCANIS: And you're going
to play your games today.
This is history 101.
Beat Bowser.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, and
I find that I have an
attitude that I'm much--
and this is totally a
connoisseur thing.
I'm less concerned about
content level and
appropriateness as in
terms of quality.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's what
I was wondering is like my
daughter is still a little
young for games, but I've
started looking at what games
are out there for kids.
WOLFF DOBSON: It hurts
sometimes.
TODD KERPELMAN: There's a lot
that just aren't very good.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, you just sit
there and go like, this is
not a game.
You can't play this because
it annoys me.
It's like, let's bring
on something decent.
And actually, the new Super
Mario Brothers with the four
people playing at
the same time?
My wife and I and my daughter
will all sit around
and play this game.
And since it's got the catch-up
feature where she
can, when it gets hard, she
just bubbles and follows
wherever we're going, it's
really good, and it's
appropriate.
But I also have her playing
Dragon Age, which is probably
not appropriate.
I'm a bad parent.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The
SRB disapproves.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: I was actually
saying I think you will see
more games like what Nintendo is
doing where multiple people
of varying skill levels can
play together in the same
environment.
Like Mario Galaxy 2, I believe,
just has that feature
where it's like one person who
can deal with manipulating the
camera and jumping over these
crazy 3D jumps, and one person
just goes around and
collects the stuff.
I think a lot of that
is perfect for--
COLT MCANIS: Besides
the fact that--
[BEEPING]
[GROANING]
COLT MCANIS: Besides the fact
that being a crazy game, they
actually got that design
mechanic right.
The rest of the game was--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We
didn't get to my
opinion as a gaming parent.
WOLFF DOBSON: You tell us.
What should your parents
have done for you?
COLT MCANIS: I thought we were
over the five minute line.
TODD KERPELMAN: We are,
but real quick.
WOLFF DOBSON: You get
two sentences.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Uhhhhhh.
COLT MCANIS: Haiku it.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's
not a sentence.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, let's
go to the next one.
TODD KERPELMAN: I am
so glad that we
extended time for that.
[LAUGHTER]
WOLFF DOBSON: When it comes time
to edit, I think I know
where we're going.
TODD KERPELMAN: Here's
my next question.
So the mobile space, all we've
been hearing is free to play,
free to play, free to play.
That's the big trend.
Everything's going
free to play.
And then last month, two
months ago, Square Enix
releases Final Fantasy III
for like $16, $17,
something like that.
And it is A, very well received
by the community.
People say, well,
it's expensive,
but it's a good game.
It's worth it, and has
been doing fairly
well for them, I think.
And in fact, they just announced
The World Ends with
You is coming to mobile for like
$20, something like that.
So my question is, do we think
this is the start of a trend
where we're going to start
seeing the free to play games,
but the games where you're going
to pay for them upfront
are actually going to
be more expensive.
They're going to be in the $15
to $20 range and that $1 to $3
range is now no-man's land?
WOLFF DOBSON: You get to answer
this first since you're
not a parent.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I hope so.
I've been playing Final Fantasy
III on my Nexus phone,
and it's awesome.
It is a great--
WOLFF DOBSON: Wow.
Those guys back in the day, they
knew how to write a game.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
no kidding.
It's a great game.
It's a great port, and
the experience works.
I mean, a lot of the more
expensive premium games
require very intricate controls,
like Wolff was
talking about.
But Final Fantasy
is a turn-based
game for all battles.
So it works really
well on a phone.
And I hope to see
more of them.
COLT MCANIS: Yeah, I think
that we're going
to see more of this.
I think this is not
just a fad.
I think that Square Enix is the
right company to come out
and do this.
They have a great catalog
of amazing content.
I mean, we all grew up idolizing
the game, wasting
our lives playing these.
Not wasting our lives, but
having lots of fun playing
these games.
And I think we're going to see
a lot more of these companies
that have back catalog of
content bringing it over to
this new medium and creating
new content.
Because right now, let's admit
it, the $0.99 thing is fun and
awesome, but sometimes you
just want something more.
And I think they're finding
this new ecosystem.
Because we've seen it happen
on Steam, right?
Steam, the price cap was
actually pretty high, and then
we started seeing that $12 to
$18 range of titles start
coming through the door and
actually doing very well and
monetizing very well there.
And I think it's about time
to come over to mobile.
I'm encouraged by this.
I want to see more of it.
WOLFF DOBSON: There's
a repertory theater
aspect to it, too.
Where we're taking the games
that do work, unlike--
I love Pen Pen Triicelon.
I do.
It's a very strange game.
COLT MCANIS: From the name, I
would not have expected that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We're getting
the greatest hits, right?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
We're going back and we're
sorting through these things.
And what are the things that--
where the UI isn't crazy and
the cameras work and things
like that, and
bringing them forward.
And in cases like Nintendo,
they're actually re-imagining
some of these things
a little bit.
Like when you sit down and play
New Super Mario Bros.,
you're like, oh, this world is
shaped like that other world,
but is not quite the same.
It's a little easier.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The thing is,
even though we are getting the
greatest hits, Final Fantasy III
is showing that that genre
and structure of game can work
in the mobile space.
COLT MCANIS: Which we've
been missing, right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So maybe we're
going to get new content, new
games, that are of that same
structure, but they're modern.
WOLFF DOBSON: There's an aspect
where Square Enix has
spent millions upon millions
of dollars marketing these
games when they originally
launch, so they have this
incredible warm feeling
when they come out.
If I were a custom developer,
a new developer who also had
ambitions to build the next
great Final Fantasy, marketing
becomes a real important
question there.
Like where are you going to
get the money to build the
brand awareness so that when
people come there, they're
like, damn, I'm spending
$15 on that.
One of the reasons why we all
went out and dropped $60 on
Final Fantasy, or $50, or $70
or whatever you paid.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: $15.
WOLFF DOBSON: At the moment
in which it came out.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, oh, you
mean way back in the day.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
Whatever day.
Whenever you bought it.
COLT MCANIS: $54.
TODD KERPELMAN: I don't know
where you bought yours, but
mine was $16.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's what
she said it cost,
so I just paid it.
No.
COLT MCANIS: You're going
to the wrong sites.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
But we wanted to pay it
because we'd seen the
trailers, and we'd seen the
things, and gotten the hype.
And we were like, yeah, $15.
I'm there, I'm going to do it.
And I think that's part of the
emotional play you have to
make as a developer.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think for
when I first played Final
Fantasy II or IV in--
WOLFF DOBSON: Depending
on which numbering
system you're using.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
The hype was the playground
hype.
It was, holy crap, I rented this
game over the weekend.
It was amazing.
COLT MCANIS: Renting.
You remember back when
kids rented games?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, yes.
COLT MCANIS: Wow.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Get on your
bicycle, bike over to--
COLT MCANIS: I'm so old.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: --Jumbo Video,
and get yourself a game.
Yes, yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: You'd have the
instruction manual that was
typewritten because that was
the one thing that they
couldn't actually--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I actually
remember
going with my friends--
maybe this doesn't translate
to America-- but Canadian
Tire, where they actually have
their own currency, Canadian
Tire Dollars.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh yeah, they have
their own credit cards
and stuff, too.
It's like the most popular
credit card in Canada.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, Canadian
Tire currency, it's like you
get maybe 1% back on
all your purchases.
And my friend somehow saved up
$70 worth of Canadian Tire
money and bought Final
Fantasy II.
I remember going on that trip.
COLT MCANIS: That should somehow
become a T-shirt.
I don't know how, where.
If you make T-shirts and you're
watching this stream,
make that into a T-shirt.
I will buy it.
Also, if you're out there and
you make T-shirts and you make
any Metriod T-shirts, I
will also buy those
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right.
COLT MCANIS: Got to represent
the Metroid.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
We have 10 seconds left.
COLT MCANIS: Even in 10 seconds,
I want to say this,
is that I really do want to come
back to the concept of
how do indie developers market
in this new economy because
there's a lot of stuff
there that we don't--
WOLFF DOBSON: I think that's
a great topic.
We could do a whole
show on that.
COLT MCANIS: Yeah, absolutely.
[BEEPING]
COLT MCANIS: Write that down.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wait.
Sorry, my thing--
all right.
Well, that was sort of
one of our topics.
WOLFF DOBSON: I don't
know how to stop it.
COLT MCANIS: This modern
technology.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, less
business-y talk, more
game-y talk.
COLT MCANIS: Ooh.
TODD KERPELMAN: Favorite
boss fight.
Start with you, John.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right.
TODD KERPELMAN: Or
most memorable.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Actually,
Final Fantasy IV.
The end boss, Zeromus.
The very same friends who went
to Canadian Tire and bought
this game, we spent an
entire summer trying
to beat this boss.
We made it all the way through
the game and then got stuck.
And we just had to-- we
started-- it was my first
experience grinding in a
game, just leveling up
and leveling up.
And it was this huge trek
just to get to the boss.
There was no save spot right
next to the boss, so it was
maybe half an hour of game play
to get from the closest
save spot to the boss,
only to lose again,
and again, and again.
But the music and the graphics,
it was amazing.
TODD KERPELMAN: I was going to
say, that doesn't sound like a
positive experience.
That sounds like--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It
was, though.
WOLFF DOBSON: But you felt
good when you were done.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, when
we finally succeeded.
WOLFF DOBSON: If you keep
slamming your hand in the car
door, eventually it feels
great to stop.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, this was,
I guess, a different era
of gaming when we're all sitting
together in front of a
television, five of us playing
and sharing the controllers
and passing it around and
trying and trying again.
So maybe it's more the time
I had with my friends.
But I will always remember the
music and the graphics.
And when you think you've beaten
him, he does his death
animation and then re-spawns
in an even tougher mode.
COLT MCANIS: Multi-stage boss.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, final,
final, final form.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Just the
strategy in that was so
difficult because you needed a
white mage to constantly be
healing and reviving people, and
then hoping that your turn
to get an attack
comes before--
because he had a
one-hit attack.
If he attacked one of
your characters,
they were just dead.
It didn't matter how many
hit points you had.
So you constantly had to be
reviving them and getting the
timing right so you get in one
hit before you're killed.
It was awesome.
COLT MCANIS: I like
your strategy.
For me, so many to pick from.
One of the most memorable, I
have to say, I ever had was
actually Super Mario RPG.
This was actually-- so I had
missed the RPG genre until
Super Mario RPG and loved
it, absolutely fell
in love with it.
There was one boss fight, and
it wasn't really a boss.
It was actually just one
of the monsters--
the NPCs in the game--
Jinx.
I don't know if you remember
this, but in Monster Town,
there was a specific door that
you could open that would
actually go, and you could fight
a little dude that was
only like 8 pixels tall.
His name was Jinx, and he
was a martial arts dojo.
And I remember this fight more
than anything else because I
could beat everyone
else in the game.
I actually beat the game, beat
the end boss-- the sword
dude-- came back, and still
couldn't beat this guy.
I actually spent more time
trying to beat him, leveling
up and trying to figure him out,
then I did the rest of
the game entirely.
That stuck out to me because
it was an entire summer.
Like you said, it was just an
entire summer of trying to
figure out this guy's
patterns.
And I learned more about how to
play the game fighting that
one guy than the rest
of the game.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
I'm going to give my--
WOLFF DOBSON: What about you?
Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: --two quick
ones, which are the giant fish
in the lake in Resident
Evil 4.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh yes.
That was a good fight.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
was a good fight.
It was just--
WOLFF DOBSON: That whole game
is really interesting.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That
game is so good.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
was a good game.
Yeah, I mean, there were a lot
of good boss fights in that.
WOLFF DOBSON: With the Wii
controls, too, it was
something else.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I played it on
the GameCube, and then I got
it again on the Wii.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, on the
Wii, it's just amazing.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I wasn't a
huge fan of Resident Evil
until Resident Evil 4, and
that just completely--
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, I
spend quality time
with Resident Evil.
TODD KERPELMAN: And that was
like the very first boss fight
that you really had in that
game, and it just--
yeah.
It was a thrill ride.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Actually, I
think the first one is the mob
in that city.
That took me--
like in that rural town,
that was really hard.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
felt like a movie.
That felt like movie pacing,
where it's like--
I don't know if you remember the
remake of Dawn of the Dead
where you've got that crazy
sequence at the beginning
where Sarah Polley is trying to
get away from her household
and finally ends up crashing
in a ditch.
And you realize you've been
tense the whole time, and then
the opening credits come up.
It was kind of that feeling
with Resident Evil 4.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, it was.
WOLFF DOBSON: All
right, so two.
Second boss.
Oh, was that your--
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, yeah.
The second boss.
I'll just-- real quick.
This is this somewhat obscure
game called Warning Forever.
It was a Windows freeware
game that was released
several years ago.
I really want somebody out
there to do a remake.
I will buy it.
So you got one customer.
COLT MCANIS: Kickstarter
project there.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
would be fantastic.
WOLFF DOBSON: Warning Forever?
TODD KERPELMAN: The entire
game was just fighting.
It was--
WOLFF DOBSON: Holy cow.
TODD KERPELMAN: --a little
spaceship battle.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Freeware
2D fixed.
TODD KERPELMAN: The entire game
was fighting just these
giant, giant boss spaceships.
And every time you defeated
one, the game would
algorithmically determine, oh,
OK, you spent your time
attacking this way, and you
got hit more often by this
weapon, and would evolve and
dynamically create another
boss monster for you.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's a game that
hates you even more.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the
game looks a lot like
Life Force or Gradius.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, it's
that kind of Life Force,
Gradius kind of theme.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's
a bullet hell.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh,
great games.
[BEEPING]
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, but I'm
going to go anyway.
TODD KERPELMAN: Go anyway.
WOLFF DOBSON: My favorite boss
battle is from Pathways into
Darkness, the giant blue worm
that comes after you.
You walk through this maze
and it takes forever.
And you go and you go and you
go, and then the guy is there.
And all the way through, you're
picking up M16 ammo.
And it's a survival
horror thing.
So he's like, I have
so much ammo.
Oh, this is so good.
It was like the first survival
horror game I'd ever played
because it's back on the Mac.
Bungie, it's one of their
very first games.
Get up there, and you're
like, woo, [GASP]
monster.
And so you start loading your
M16 and you're stepping
backwards because it's going at
the same rate that you can
walk backwards.
And you end up walking backwards
for what felt like
an hour, but probably is more
like about 2 minutes, backing
up through the maze, unloading
everything, and then running
out of M16.
And now you're back into your
regular ammo, which you were
saving for this thing.
And you're doing all that, and
then you're eventually
stabbing with your knife.
And it dies like right as
you get out of the maze.
UH!
It's beautiful.
And it actually goes to what the
role of AI in games is in
the first place.
And to me, it's always to lose,
but at the last minute.
And this was our organizing
principle when
we were doing AI.
It's like it wants to push
you, but then, aargh.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So was it
actually set up so that--
WOLFF DOBSON: Absolutely.
They knew exactly how many
bullets that you had, and they
knew how strong to make it.
They knew what to
make the thing.
And then actually, when I was
playing a Resident Evil game,
there was a--
it was Resident Evil
maybe Code--
Vernoica?
I can't remember.
And at one point, you switch
characters and you have to go
through this thing.
And Resident Evil has those
boxes that you put stuff in,
and then it appears
someplace else.
It's like the uniform box.
And so I was like, oh, this
other guy's got this really
tough thing.
So I took my regular character
and filled the box with
everything.
All she had was a pistol
and three bullets.
And then that character went
off, and then I went to the
character, and he had this
difficult quest,
and he comes back.
And then he meets up with her
and gives her the antidote.
And then all of a sudden,
a boss battle starts.
And he is separated.
And I was like, oh god, I
only have three bullets.
But the guys at Capcom
had predicted that.
And sure enough, I went bang,
bang, bang, and the guy died.
And I was like, oh, I see.
It has as many hit points
as I have bullets.
I win!
And I had all this
extra shotgun--
COLT MCANIS: I want some of
those bullets in every game.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, exactly.
All right.
So anyway, let's keep going.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, we're
going to keep going.
Next question.
Favorite setting, as in like
fantasy world, not like oh,
I'm going to configure
the anti-alias thing.
That you feel like is--
WOLFF DOBSON: My favorite
setting is
the anti-alias thing.
TODD KERPELMAN: The land
of anti-alias.
COLT MCANIS: DLAA.
WOLFF DOBSON: Is it favorite
setting, or is it favorite
least used setting?
TODD KERPELMAN: Favorite setting
that you feel is
underutilized, that you'd
like to see more of.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes?
TODD KERPELMAN: Are you--
WOLFF DOBSON: Are we
looking at me?
JIMMY: Your mike needs
to be adjusted.
Fix your mike.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh?
TODD KERPELMAN: Hold on.
We're taking a break for
technical difficulties.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, it's OK.
You guys--
COLT MCANIS: Are we paused
or are we live?
TODD KERPELMAN: Why don't
you go while we're--
COLT MCANIS: Yeah.
So I really think that
fantasy is overdone.
I know it's probably the
most popular genre
that's out there today.
I think like 70% of all games
are actually fantasy.
People get it.
People understand it.
But to me, it's just
way overdone.
I know what a paladin is, I know
what a cleric is, give me
something cooler.
To be honest, I love the
slapstick style of things like
Super Mario Bros.
I know that's not a specific
genre like an art style, but
that sort of slapstick
environment where the
developer is not even
taking themselves
seriously in a lot of cases.
Like I'm an Italian plumber, I'm
hopping on evil mushrooms,
and then I'm going inside of
pipes to collect coins.
Like what is that?
Who even--
so I really love those crazy
slapstick games.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's Italy.
COLT MCANIS: Yeah, I've
never been to Italy.
WOLFF DOBSON: I apologize to
our abroad Italian viewers.
Did you--
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, I forgot
to set the timer.
WOLFF DOBSON: Did you ever play
the Grasshopper games
like No More Heroes and
No More Heroes 2?
COLT MCANIS: Oh yeah, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Those are
very slapstick.
COLT MCANIS: Exactly.
WOLFF DOBSON: I find them very
loose technically, and so I
get frustrated.
This is the quality
over everything.
I get frustrated by the game
play when it's like--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, the
aesthetic of those games is so
interesting.
No More Heroes was so weird,
like so much of that game was
mowing lawns.
WOLFF DOBSON: It was a strange,
strange game.
COLT MCANIS: Well, you
can't be a hero while
you're mowing a lawn.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You got
to earn some money.
COLT MCANIS: Yeah, but
I really like that.
I feel that we're missing
that in the modern area.
We've got like the Plants vs.
Zombies styles, which kind of
takes itself seriously,
but doesn't.
And I feel that's a great
setting that we need more of.
TODD KERPELMAN: More sort
of humor, not like
maybe explicit humor?
COLT MCANIS: I'm sorry, game
developers take themselves way
too seriously.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, you don't
think every game should be
brown and with light blue.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Don't
forget the crates.
COLT MCANIS: Crates,
post-processing effects.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
COLT MCANIS: It makes
it look real.
WOLFF DOBSON: Time to crate.
You know about that measure.
It was every game is rated on
the number of seconds until
the first crate appears.
COLT MCANIS: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: I've even seen
slapstick games put a crate
just in the middle of nowhere.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Doesn't Quake
II start with crate?
COLT MCANIS: Doom.
Doom starts with crates.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, Doom,
the very first thing--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Every hit
game starts with crates.
COLT MCANIS: There's a website
that ranks all
these, isn't there?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
This is number of seconds
to crate.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's what
we're talking about, number of
seconds until you see
a crate in the game.
COLT MCANIS: I talked too
long, who's next?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: What's
the question?
COLT MCANIS: We're talking
about crates.
TODD KERPELMAN: Underutilized
settings.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think
underutilized settings,
warehouses.
COLT MCANIS: We need more
warehouses and parking garages.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Spooky
mansions, warehouses.
Castles.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's good.
I was going to say I didn't
think I liked Westerns until I
played Red Dead Redemption.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's
a great game.
TODD KERPELMAN: The
setting is good.
I was thinking about it on the
way over, that probably you
couldn't have a good Western
game until this generation of
hardware, just because the
worlds are so open and you
don't have to worry about
cutting off the viewer's view
every 20 feet.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well,
and like foliage.
Let's be honest, getting plants
looking good is a very
recent phenomenon.
COLT MCANIS: Wait, isn't--
It's a Western.
It's supposed to be
in the desert.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, no, but--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WOLFF DOBSON: But there
are plants.
COLT MCANIS: There
are some plants.
I will allow that.
WOLFF DOBSON: Westerns don't
take place in the Sahara.
TODD KERPELMAN: I probably
spent 10 hours collecting
flowers in Red Dead
Redemption.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, that
was the thing.
I mean, the design goal of that
is to have you look at
all the plants, right?
I mean, every game has these
quests where it's like, look
at the terrain very carefully
because we paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars to mark
up all these things.
COLT MCANIS: Some graphics
programmer's like, no, no, no.
This is a quest.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're going to
look at my frickin' fountain.
That's what I'm saying.
Do you know how long
that took?
TODD KERPELMAN: But the problem
with that is I end up
looking at the mini-map
the whole time.
Because I think when those
icons started showing up.
WOLFF DOBSON: See, that's a
whole gamer rant there.
It's like, mini-map,
not mini-map.
Did you see The Getaway, where
they were going to get rid of
the mini-map?
SCEE did The Getaway,
which is this game.
One of the design goals of the
game was there was going to be
no mini-map.
COLT MCANIS: Oh wow.
WOLFF DOBSON: Because it
was an open world game.
[BEEPING]
WOLFF DOBSON: They had
rigged all of London.
All right, underused--
London.
No, it's very overused.
And actually, my favorite
setting ever for a video game
was the inside of the Arc de
Triomphe in Onimusha 3.
COLT MCANIS: Oh wow, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: That
was awesome.
But anyway, yeah, they
have no mini-map.
But they still had to tell
you where to drive.
And so what happens is in the
middle of these crazy car
chases, your guy will signal.
And he'll be, oh, I
should turn right.
COLT MCANIS: Brilliant.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is pretty smart.
WOLFF DOBSON: It was cool at
the beginning because you
really have this intense kind
of movie-like experience.
But after a while,
it got ludicrous.
You're like, why
am I signaling?
I'm being chased by
like 70 cops.
And I'm like, you know what I
need to do, I need to signal.
COLT MCANIS: Well, you
have to obey the law.
You don't want to
get pulled over.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: You should
signal one way and then turn
the other direction.
WOLFF DOBSON: Ohh.
TODD KERPELMAN: And that'll
throw them off.
WOLFF DOBSON: You know, if we
had better AI, we'd be able to
do stuff like this.
What's our next topic?
COLT MCANIS: Did John go?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, I was
going to say, why don't we
have John go.
And we are running
low on time.
I'm going to save this next one
because it's a big topic,
probably for next time.
That'll be like a teaser.
Two weeks from now.
COLT MCANIS: Tune in.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Something
suburban North America.
It's a very underutilized
setting for a game.
WOLFF DOBSON: Have you
been to the suburbs?
TODD KERPELMAN: Suburban
North America.
WOLFF DOBSON: Nothing happens.
COLT MCANIS: You mean like
Mars Attacks! style?
Paperboy type stuff?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: The Simpsons.
WOLFF DOBSON: Martians Ate
My Neighbors or whatever.
What was it?
Zombies Ate My Neighbors?
COLT MCANIS: Zombies
Ate My Neighbors.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, Zombies
Ate My Neighbors,
that kind of setting.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I actually
think realistic settings are
not-- or modern time settings,
they're difficult, because you
end up with uncanny valley
problems and the "why is there
a crate in my wife's bedroom?"
kind of questions.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Time
to crates.
COLT MCANIS: That
is a question.
WOLFF DOBSON: Definitely
a little
weird there or something.
COLT MCANIS: I thought Modern
Warfare 2 did it well.
They had an urban map, which was
effectively just a shooter
on rails that I really wish they
could've explored more of
the ecosystem there.
But I thought they did
it really well.
They had an urban environment.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, when people
do it, and I mean,
Grand Theft Auto IV, obviously,
you feel when
you're driving through parts of
it, you're like, my friend
lives right here.
But, in general, I think it's a
way to bring in players who
aren't science fiction and
fantasy fans and be like, this
is something you know, and now
I'm going to do something
weird to it to make it
interesting for you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: But like Zombies
Ate My Neighbors, or
whatever that game was called,
it could be in that suburban
setting, and then
sci-fi happens.
WOLFF DOBSON: Mm-hm.
COLT MCANIS: Can you mix
a sci-fi and a zombie?
WOLFF DOBSON: Sci-fi zombies?
Sure.
Haven't you watched any of
the Resident Evil movies?
COLT MCANIS: Well--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's
sci-zombies.
COLT MCANIS: That's
zombieized.
TODD KERPELMAN: Serenity?
COLT MCANIS: Serenity?
Really Fair enough.
Fair enough.
Reapers?
That's one.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
I guess they were.
They were pretty much zombies.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sci-fi zombies.
TODD KERPELMAN: There you go.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There's
rules, though, and you
just don't do it.
COLT MCANIS: Well, yeah.
Like vampires shouldn't
sparkle.
Let's just get that out
of the way right now.
Make sure everyone knows where
I stand on this issue.
WOLFF DOBSON: If you are a
viewer and you do believe
vampires should sparkle,
I think you need
to comment on that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Let us know.
I had some follow-up questions
for next episode.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
that sounds good.
We didn't have really any
questions this time.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, that's OK.
TODD KERPELMAN: Maybe because we
didn't answer most of them
from last time.
Next time--
WOLFF DOBSON: Learn
helplessness.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'd like you to
fill out some questions--
WOLFF DOBSON: Wait, wait.
COLT MCANIS: Jimmy?
Jimmy, we have a question?
Jimmy, can we go to the live
feed of the question?
What do we got?
TODD KERPELMAN: Hold on.
WOLFF DOBSON: Hold on.
He's got to type faster.
COLT MCANIS: Jimmy?
Jimmy, we need that
on this monitor.
Jimmy?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We
got a question.
TODD KERPELMAN: Ooh.
WOLFF DOBSON: We have
a question!
COLT MCANIS: Fantastic.
TODD KERPELMAN: "Where do you
see gaming going with
technology like Hangouts?" I
don't know if there's anyone
here that really
knows Hangouts.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, who
works on Hangouts?
Oh, oh.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wolff.
COLT MCANIS: That guy.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think the--
TODD KERPELMAN: Good question.
Thank you, by the way.
WOLFF DOBSON: There are a lot
of interesting things to do
with Hangouts.
I think Hangouts are--
one of the things I say a lot
when we talk about Hangouts is
that Hangouts are a
room where you've
gathered a bunch of people.
And then Hangout apps are the
kitchen table that they're all
sitting around.
It's the thing that they're all
looking at and sharing.
And you were talking
about the couch
experience with your friends.
I think having a strict "watch
me play" kind of thing might
not be as much fun if it's a
little screen and you're going
to look away kind of thing.
But I think a situation in
which we're sharing an
experience together and we
can talk to each other.
And I actually think
that games--
I would love it if somebody--
actually, we had that
at a hackathon.
Somebody had the OpenGL Quake
running in a Hangout.
They demoed it at the University
of Washington, a
hackathon we had in January.
They had that.
It was really neat.
I did find my attention tended
to focus on the shooting part
and not nearly as
much on the--
COLT MCANIS: Other
people part.
WOLFF DOBSON: On the people,
people's heads.
So I think you're going
to have to bring
the faces into the--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Just put
them on the crates.
So every crate you pass
by will just have--
TODD KERPELMAN: Have someone's
face on it.
COLT MCANIS: So was this--
this was that each person had
their own instance of Quake--
WOLFF DOBSON: They were all
playing Quake together.
COLT MCANIS: Got it.
WOLFF DOBSON: But they
had the lineup of--
COLT MCANIS: And this is--
I just want to make sure because
this is different than
what you would standardly see,
which is like, hey, we're all
in a Hangout, and we all
see the same thing.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah that's
the YouTube watching
somebody else play.
COLT MCANIS: Got it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Like there's the
guy who plays all the modern
games and people shout
stuff at him.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Now what
about tabletop games?
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, well, there's
Tabletop Forge, which
we've talked about before
on the show.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Because I'm
pretty sure some Facebook
friends of mine play D&D--
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh god, yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: --over
Hangouts.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, and see,
that's a situation in which
the people matter a lot
in that situation.
And I think that's what makes
Hangout games fun.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, because
that was really about like--
COLT MCANIS: And shouldn't they
be your Google+ friends?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
They are, yeah.
COLT MCANIS: OK.
I was just trying
to figure out--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: What'd I say?
Did I have to list some
other social network?
TODD KERPELMAN: I would like
to see parlor games.
I'd like to see more
like charades.
I feel like you can't do
charades in any other
environment--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Pictionary.
TODD KERPELMAN: --beyond,
yeah.
Or even a game like Balderdash,
which in theory--
so it's the game where you have
this word that no one
really knows.
Everyone writes definitions for
it and try and guess which
one's real.
I feel like if I were just doing
that in a chat room,
everyone would be going off to
Google and looking up the
word, and then it wouldn't
be any fun.
I feel like in a Hangout, the
fact that you can see other
people's faces, and you know who
they are, and you're all
playing together, somehow I
think would add that extra
peer pressure to actually play
by the rules and play well.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I mean,
that's why RPGs work, that
we're all in a shared experience
together and we're
going to enforce the rules on
each other, although it's
harder to cheat on dice rolls
using Tabletop Forge because
actually everyone
sees the roll.
COLT MCANIS: So quick
question here.
So there's two separate discrete
versions right now
that we're talking about, which
is the YouTube style
"watch me play," and
then everyone
has their own version.
Can you do both with the
current Hangout APIs?
Like it would be fantastic.
I see a scenario here where
we're playing poker or
something, and we have this
shared environment
that we can all see.
But then we each have our own
little view that we can
manipulate before it
goes in, right?
Like I've got my view
of the ecosystem.
I've got my cards in my
hand that I can see.
But yet you can see on this
larger screen what everyone
else has written.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh no,
we do that already.
COLT MCANIS: Oh cool.
So you can actually get
two separate feeds.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's really
just one feed.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
it's one feed.
But you're--
well, OK.
You can share your screen, which
is going to give you
some view of what it is that
you're seeing on your desktop
right then.
But games like--
well, games like WarLight
there's a shared map.
But you see what you see through
fog of war, and other
people see what they see
through fog of war.
So we have that.
And if someone decided to haul
out and make a bridge game,
then that would be a great
thing where you have your
cards yourself.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: My grandmother
would love it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
COLT MCANIS: But would your
grandma haul out and make it?
WOLFF DOBSON: Is she
going to sit down?
Hack that out?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No, it's hard
enough to get her to turn on
the computer.
WOLFF DOBSON: And actually,
interestingly, you can run two
Hangout apps at once if you
really wanted to have side
chat like that.
Because you can run the
extension on the side--
COLT MCANIS: That would
be great for Catan.
WOLFF DOBSON: But
anyway, yeah.
Like I said, games where people
are important I think
are games where Hangouts are
going to be exciting.
And I mean, I think
lots of games
are exciting in Hangouts.
Those are the games I'm
most excited about.
COLT MCANIS: Very cool.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
COLT MCANIS: Jimmy, do we have
any more on the live feed?
TODD KERPELMAN: That's it.
COLT MCANIS: No?
OK.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Any questions
from Jimmy?
COLT MCANIS: Jimmy?
No.
Jimmy's just an intern.
It's OK.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we are
just about out of time.
Like I said, we'll save this
topic for next time.
COLT MCANIS: Do you want
to announce it?
TODD KERPELMAN: No, no, we'll
keep it a secret.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well, that
might lead to questions.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh,
that's true.
All right, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Why don't you
announce the topic?
TODD KERPELMAN: We
are going to be
talking about app discovery.
WOLFF DOBSON: App discovery?
TODD KERPELMAN: App discovery.
WOLFF DOBSON: What kinds of
apps are we discovering?
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, so this
kind of started with a article
that you had sent me about the
game 10000000, spelled one,
zero, zero, zero, zero.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, with no
commas, which meant I had no
idea how many zeroes
were on it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Which makes it
very difficult to find on
search, which--
TODD KERPELMAN: Which
sort of--
WOLFF DOBSON: Although, not
actually that hard because you
type "100," or a random number
of zeroes, and then type
"game," and then it will say,
"do you mean "10000000"?
COLT MCANIS: I love
Google sometimes.
TODD KERPELMAN: We're
smart like that.
WOLFF DOBSON: I misspelled
"ermahgern." Because I was
looking for the meme, and it
said "do you mean "ermahgern"?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So a picture
of the meme?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
No, no.
It just said, "do you
mean "ermahgern"?
And I was like, yes,
yes, I do.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
we're out of time.
Next week, app discovery.
We'll give you more background
next time.
WOLFF DOBSON: Keep those cards
and letters coming in.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, keep the
questions coming and--
COLT MCANIS: Jimmy, get that
out of your mouth.
TODD KERPELMAN: Jimmy's so--
COLT MCANIS: Interns.
TODD KERPELMAN: Jimmy
is irrepressible.
That's what he is.
COLT MCANIS: He's
chewing on our--
OK.
If you get shocked again,
it's on you.
All right, that's all for us?
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
all for us.
Hopefully, they're
fading us out.
And we can continue to do that
thing where we chat while
they're fading out.
COLT MCANIS: Well, that's
an actual valid thing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]